there are plenty of visible signs of how
Russia's business world has been
transformed by the invasion of Ukraine
and the sanctions that followed stores
belonging to the Spanish clothing brand
Zara are to reopen in June as mag owned
by a firm registered in a UAE free zone
Ikea has packed up its flat packed
furniture and left the Russian Market
belarus's Swede is filling the Gap but
there's a deeper problem that new
signage can't address these reopened
businesses need staff
taking into account the historically
minimal unemployment rate of 3.5 percent
in the country there are simply not
enough workers in many areas
in last year that affected hundreds of
thousands of people and forced nearly a
million to flee abroad
so training at technical colleges like
this one in Moscow is all the more
necessary
all our programs are in demand for
example for design we have a competition
of about 22 people per place every block
is in demand
sixteen-year-old Dimitri kochev is a
civil engineering student even though
he's in his first year of a three-year
program he's got big plans for his
future
I chose this specialty because I wanted
to be a builder and I like working with
my hands after training I plan to go to
work on site and earn money to open my
own business later about 40 percent of
Russians are employed by the state
state-owned companies or private
companies whose owners have closed
government ties making them a natural
destination for these students since the
state is paying for their entire
education
there's already a huge demand for these
students even before they finish their
degrees given the economic isolation
facing Russia by Western Powers
investing in these teenagers future is a
secure bet the country can minimize the
impact of that isolation
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Moscow